[Musique]
dans les beaux quartiers de paris un
restaurant clandestins réservé à une
clientèle huppée
ici les menus varient entre 160 et 490
euros
le procureur de paris rémy heitz a
ouvert une enquête pénale après un
reportage de m6 des soirées auxquelles
auraient pu participer des ministres
selon les affirmations d'une source
anonyme à la chaîne et 10 défaites
semaine dans deux ou trois restaurants
qui sont justement d'ailleurs des
restaurants au studio clamp des avec un
certain nombre de ministres alors ça me
fait doucement rigoler on est encore en
démocratie on fait ce qu'on veut elle
pas les milliers mais bon on peut
émettre des lumières on peut donc le
samu les heureusement qu'on peut faire
face à un côté c'est une personnalité
bien connue du petit écran
pierre-jean chalencon un collectionneur
passionné d'histoire mais aussi
propriétaire de cet espace de réception
à paris le palais vivienne
depuis plusieurs semaines il y aurait
organisé dans l'illégalité des repas
payant avec le chef christophe leroy et
j'ai demandé immédiatement après cette
police de paris d'enquêter sur les faits
qui sont annoncés dans ce reportage
soit ils sont faux et il ne faut pas
jeter l'opprobe évidemment soit ils sont
vrais et évidemment sur le travail que
pourra faire les services de police les
personnes doivent pouvoir être poursuivi
le ministre de l'intérieur a pris les
choses au sérieux et jouer pas faire
autrement
taxis ne faisait pas le sentiment qu'il
était en train de couvrir ses collègues
du gouvernement et donc il était obligé
de le faire et donc chacun d'un ministre
qui a dîné quelque part qu'est ce qui
fait une des niches r notre vie et je
pense que pour lui ça va être compliqué
au groupe pour les gueules c'est 135
euros d'amendé vous avez rappelé cette
histoire dans le sud avec le cette
famille qui s'est pris 405 euros damende
pour un peu de rose et sur une plage
avec autour 15 policiers le fusil
d'assaut à l'image n'était sorti par
midi libre
et puis à relier les villes et le plus
jeune qu'on embête etc
et puis à la haute la caste qui
s'amusent qui est dans un discours
absolument hypocrite selon l' agence
france presse pierre jean chalencon
propriétaire des lieux reconnaît
implicitement être l'un des
organisateurs un temps évoqué la
présence de ministres à ses repas a été
écarté par l'avocat du collectionneur
justifiant une pointe d'humour de son
clan
quand je trouve cette affaire assez
fumeuse en fait d'ailleurs maintenant le
principal accusateur des ministres dit
bah non c'était de l'humour donc bien
sûr il faut une enquête pour savoir s'il
existe des restaurants clandestins s'ils
existent il faut les faire mais il faut
sanctionner mais bon ça fait quinze mois
qui nous emmerde pas fait 15 mois qu'on
n'en peut plus rien faire
moi j'ai pas eu un euro dead je fais ce
que je suis encore en france ou encore
un citoyen normal pour qu'on arrête les
mecs
faites moi j'y crois pas je crois
vraiment pas que mes collègues puissent
aller dans des restaurants clandestins
donc c'est vraiment une hypothèse qui
paraît pas solide du tout comme unique
mode dans ce gouvernement
d'accord mais ils sont pas si tu vas
certainement pas un assez stupides ils
vont râler s'exposer dans une boîte ou
yahoo il ya 40 mais qu'ils sont capables
de les prendre en photo et femmes
qu'est-ce qui va arrêter le hashtag
saccage paris qui est devenu tendance
dès vendredi sur twitter avec des
milliers de photos postées une ville
défigurée une déchetterie des mots très
durs des images chocs pêle mêle la
saleté dans les rues de paris
ce n'est pas la première fois que la
capitale est sous le feu des critiques
en 2019 déjà la presse britannique avait
élu paris ville la plus sale d'europe
si effectivement nous devions atteindre
le pic cette semaine je le souhaite j'en
ai pas encore la démonstration mais ça
commence à frémir par endroits donc on
peut on a quelques raisons d'espérer
dans ce cas-là ça voudrait dire que deux
à trois semaines plus tard nous aurions
le pic de réanimation qui sera élevé
puisque vous avez vu nous sommes déjà
plus de cinq mille malades
je ne m'exprime pas sur ce sujet donc
elle n'est pas de vous cette phrase je
je ne crois pas l'avoir dit je crois pas
non en tout cas je suis pas sûr d'avoir
dit publiquement peut-être
publiquement chypre